So switching over to Android studio,
we need to do a couple of steps before
we can extract a palette from an image.
The first thing we need to do
in our apps build.grade file
is to add the support library for
palette as a dependency.
So after we get our resource identifier
for our image, we can convert
that into a Bitmap, that the palette
will use to generate the color swatches.
These color swatches fall
into two different areas.
Either a vibrant color or a muted color.
The type in number swatches is dependent
on the composition of your image and
how much of it is in a certain color and
how that contrasts to
other colors in the image.
If you want more information for that,
you can check the source code for
the palette library.
So right here in this code,
I take a palette and I'm looking through
all of the different swatches to see if
they exist because they can be null and
then I return that map.
So if we want to see this on a device,
make a little app here
that can show an image and
pull out the palette information.
So let's hit this floating action
button down here and pick an image,
and let's pick one of the images from
our Android kick off, and we can see
that it's created a palette for us.
Now, the interesting colors here,
I'd say, is the vibrant color
that it's picking up from
these Android stickers